The correct answer is that no persons are lost. Let's look into the reason for that.
These are the creations of the SIR Model again.
If we form the sum of these three derivatives and see that this term minus coefficient times I times S
plus the same coefficient times I times S, cancelled in the sum
and the same happens with this term, minus coefficient times I plus the same coefficient times I.
So the sum of these derivatives is zero. For simple interpretation of that left-hand side here.
If you look at this number, the number of susceptible persons
plus the number of infectious persons plus the number of recovered persons
form the derivative with respect to time, we get this expression.
The rate of change of the sum is the sum of the rates of change.
You see, in this case, I'm switching to the d/t notation
because it's hard to place the dots on top of the sum.
So what we learned is, that the rate of change of the sum is zero.
If the rate of change is zero, there is no change and if there is no change,
the sum is constant which means nobody is lost.
Persons move from susceptible to infectious and from infectious to recovered
but never move out of that system.
We could see the same equation also if there was immigration, or births and deaths
that compensate each other precisely.